earlier in the show I told you all of
the ways in which this protracted Fiasco
in the House of Representatives wherein
Republicans have been unable to elect a
speaker is bad for Republicans now
that's good that makes me happy I think
the Republican party is terrible for the
country I think their goals and
Ambitions are destructive I want them to
have a quagmire and to be unable to push
forward their disgusting agenda however
I don't want
the country to fail and as a general
principle not having a house speaker is
bad for the country and it's a national
security risk and it is a source of
instability on thebullwork.com
Joe perdicone or perticoni wrote an
article touching on some of these issues
called house is paralyzed without a
speaker creating National Security risks
and a shadow shutdown imagine if this
impasse were occurring in a presidential
inaugural year and Joe very precisely
and and astutely points out all of the
different ways in which this current
status quo is very bad including that no
one has actually been sworn into the
House of Representatives yet even though
George Santos said he was sworn in he
wasn't and we'll get to that a little
bit later and I think it's important
just to be clear about the risks that
this presents
it is I would argue even simpler than
Joe perdicone lays out it's not that
he's wrong but it's even simpler
this situation in the house where no one
has been sworn in and there is no
speaker
it can lead to a functional breakdown of
the House of Representatives the speaker
actually plays a critical role in
managing and organizing the legislative
process and with no speaker how does the
house conduct business and pass
legislation is it possible to do it is
but it's significantly more of a mess
within government no speaker and no one
sworn in causes uncertainty it causes
instability the speaker is one of the
most powerful and influential figures or
positions in Congress and the American
confidence in government is certain to
decline the uh our perception of the
ability of the house to govern is quite
low accurately because this is what
they're doing and then you say okay fine
that's that's abstract but in Practical
terms what could that mean well it can
lead to gridlock or inaction on
important issues when you think about
um debt ceiling votes or if there's a a
natural disaster of some kind a crisis
an emergency uh the need for funding in
a specific Place way or form without a
speaker and without a sworn in-house it
is significantly more difficult for the
house to actually manage those things to
respond to unforeseen events and at the
end of the day to protect the country's
interests now do I think that
Republicans don't care about that no I
think at the individual level a lot of
these Republicans would honestly say no
I do care about that I understand that
I'm concerned does that mean they should
compromise on their principles to the
extent that this situation is is uh
caused by or catalyzed by their
principles no I'm not saying that but we
have to be factual we have to be honest
we have to be realistic the longer this
goes on
the more instability is accurately
perceived by the American people and
obviously the longer it goes on the the
higher the chances are that something
could happen domestically
internationally
and in other ways that would require in
normal circumstances the involvement of
the House of Representatives and they
will then be chaotically scrambling to
try to get involved help or do something
about it so
the primary interest from the we have uh
we have conflicting interests here
each faction of the Republican party
wants to reign supreme in terms of
ultimately deciding who is going to
become speaker of the house I get that
that's politics they don't want to be
seen as the losers they don't want to be
seen as the ones who were impotent in
trying to impose their preference of
speaker that's one area the impact on
the Republican Party we've already
talked about on the other hand I hope
that I'm accurate in assessing that the
interest of the American people
is to not have to think about the House
of Representatives and what I mean by
that is yes there are some people who
are more politically engaged than others
who pay attention to when are the
midterms where is control of the Senate
where is control of the house and are
more involved in that including people
like those who listen to this program
who watch our Clips the vast majority of
the country even many of those who vote
in the midterms don't spend their days
and nights thinking about this stuff and
so if it's sort of like referees in a in
a sporting event if you're noticing the
referees if you're thinking about the
referees if the referees are
significantly present in the game
arguably it is because they are doing
something wrong or too involved or
whatever the case may be you've heard
these Sports analogies before and
likewise I would argue if the American
people are thinking about the chaos in
the House of Representatives to the
extent that it has been front and center
for the last two three days
um it is it is a bad thing it is the
type of thing where we shouldn't really
have to be thinking about it the house
is there there's a natural disaster
they're going to act they're going to
they're going to help they're going to
fund uh and that's where the National
Security risk comes here we now have a
balancing a coming together of how long
are they willing to continue this and
how tolerant will the American people be
before approval rating not only for the
house as a body where the approval
rating is always low but approval for
their individual members of Congress is
going to plummet I don't know the answer
to that but I'm guessing we're going to
start finding out about that very very
soon